how to start a clothing line with no
experience and no money so I got a great
question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys
Danny wrote in to say I'm 16 years old I
recently got the passion be an
entrepreneur I have no experience in the
field I don't have a lot of money I'm
really excited to start a business
preferably clothing line what kind of
advice do you recommend for people like
me and also I'm wondering and how I
could start it off PS I find your videos
very helpful hey Danny congrats on
finding your passion and thank you for
watching all the videos my advice for
you to get started ok you have three
steps for you the first is learn the
second is find a mentor and the third is
start part-time ok learn what I don't
want you to do is go out spend a lot of
money buy a whole bunch of inventory and
you have these t-shirts sitting in your
garage your apartment or your mom's
house or whatever because that's that's
the surefire way to fail so learn is go
out and research all of the famous
entrepreneurs that you look up to and
specifically in the clothing line
industry ok so maybe it's Jojo Armani or
maybe it's Sean Combs or maybe it's
Donald Trump or maybe it's Vera Wang
whoever it is doesn't matter go and
research these guys and look how they
got started what you're trying to do
here is learn from their mistakes see
what led them to become successful and
model their success for your own company
you got to learn because if you have no
experience you've never done this before
just like anything else you're going to
make a lot of mistakes and if you go and
learn from somebody then you're going to
increase your chances of being
successful ok
the second is get a mentor what I would
encourage you to do is go find a job
with somebody who you look up to who you
respect who's build something that you
want to build something that's still
small and manageable and easy to
understand so I would look for a company
that has 10 employees or less and is
done what you're trying to do and go
offer to work from even if it's
volunteer to get started anything
because you want to learn you're going
to understand this business and ideally
you're connected to the entrepreneur
right you're not going to go work for
sure
combs and be some low level you know
assistant and never get to talk to him
you want to deal with an entrepreneur
who's got a ten person company and
that's what you want to eventually build
up right and you're gonna get paid
ideally to make mistakes right they're
going to teach you how to overcome all
the mistakes that you're going to make
because you're brand new it's like
trying to learn any other skill you're
trying to learn a language the facts way
to do it is go to that country and
immerse yourself in learning the
language and talk to people right you're
trying to learn how to skateboard the
fastest way to do it is to go learn from
somebody who can teach you how to
skateboard right they'll get you on the
board and show you how they do it it
dramatically cuts down your learning
time you pick up things that you never
thought was possible before it didn't
even think of and it really dramatically
increases your instant success okay at
the same time you're going to be making
contacts you're going to understand how
to run that kind of business so that
when you do launch your own company
you're way ahead of the game okay the
third thing is start part time you don't
need to start this full time you need to
have tons of inventory lined up I'd look
at the sites that allow you to print on
demand you you barely make any money on
those sites okay that's the truth but
what it allows you to do is test your
concepts test your designs you don't
make a lot of money but you're not
spending any money either and I'd much
rather have you be able to test a
concept test a new t-shirt test a hoodie
whatever your line is going to be show
that it works show that people want this
so that when you go out and create your
own line all on your own you know it's
going to work right you have customers
you have momentum you have feedback
without investing thousands of dollars
into something that just sits on your
shelf or in your arms' garage that's
what I do and when you've got your first
design send it to me because I want to
check it out believe rules you're
watching like this video thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath how would you start a
clothing line with no money and
experience I'd love to hear from you
leave it in the comments and click on my
face subscribe to the channel thank you
so much I'll see you soon